- Welcome back!
I'm here with fellow
craft lover Sophia Bush,
and we're gonna learn some DIY crafts
from friend of the show and
upcycling expert, Sarah T.
That's right.
(audience applauds)
- Yay.
- All of her crafts are easy to do.
Apparently easier than some tasks.
(all laugh)
And with your kids, we
wanna revamp your rooms
and only if we-
I'm not kidding, I can't.
I don't know what's wrong with me.
If only we had someone
who could really do this.
And help me, and bring
a child's perspective.
- [Leo] Hey, I can help you!
- Please, Leo, help me!
(audience applauds)
- Hi Leo.
- Hi Sarah, hi Sophia, hi Drew.
How are you guys?
- Good.
- Leo, take over the segment.
- If you say so.
- I do say so.
It's my dear, dear,
dear friend, Leo Kelly.
I love you so much, Leo!
(audience applauds)
And Sarah, we've done
the show together before.
- Yes, ma'm.
- What are we making today?
- Well, we're gonna reuse some things
to make some cool stuff
for our room, right Leo?
- [Leo] I like re-using.
- I like re-using too.
Super important, okay.
So one thing I've noticed, being a mom,
or maybe not being a mom,
is book jackets on your
kids' books, right?
They come off, they get ripped.
But I like to keep the book jacket,
we don't wanna throw it away.
So all you need for this is a container
from around your house,
it could be like, protein
canister or something
from the kitchen.
You take the lid, you
take all the labels off,
clean it up, and you take the lid,
cut a hole.
Exacto knife, but be careful
with those kid fingers.
And then, everyone in front of you guys
have a book jacket.
You wanna open up your book jacket,
and take a little bit
of double sided tape,
and we're gonna start on our end
that has not your main picture on it.
And we're gonna just put that little bit
of double sided tape on the inside piece.
Then what you're gonna do is
you're gonna start with that piece
and we're gonna wrap it
around our container.
And then you just grab
another little piece
of double sided tape, you
guys, it's super easy.
And you just put that
right on your last piece.
Just like that, you got it, Leo.
Good job.
Drew, you got it.
And there you go, you got a little themed
piggy bank.
(audience applauds)
Or you could put tissues in it, right?
- [Leo] I like it.
- Oh, it's a piggy bank!
- This is cute.
- You got it, that's perfect.
Okay, so up next, we're
gonna do some tassels.
So I love a good tassel wall.
I like to string them on a
string and hang them on a wall.
I think it adds a really fun pop of color.
- [Drew] I like, in front
of our table right here,
we have beautiful tassels hanging.
- And these are made
out of t-shirts, y'all.
All you have to do is thrift some tees,
or your old tees, you wanna cut strips.
So this one that we're gonna be doing
is about seven feet long.
And so you wanna take your long strip,
you kind of stretch it out.
Take your book and take your long
stretched out, stringy piece of t-shirt.
And we're gonna start with that,
the bottom of the string,
right at the bottom of the book.
And then you're just gonna
wrap it around, guys.
That's it.
- [Sophia] Ooh.
- Just wrap. You got it, Leo.
There you go.
That's all you do, you
come around and you wrap.
Now remember, the bigger the
book, the longer the tassel,
the more times you wrap it,
the thicker the tassel's gonna be.
And you could customize these, right, Leo?
Didn't you say your brother's into Batman?
You could make him a black and yellow one.
So once you come around,
then what you're gonna do is you're gonna
take this little string.
You've got one little extra string.
You're gonna come up over the
top of the book like this.
And you're just gonna tie that off.
That's gonna hold all of your pieces.
In place. You got it.
Okay, so then once you
get it tied like that,
check it out.
- Ah.
- You got it?
- I'm in the process.
- [Sophia] Do you just tie it in a knot?
- Yeah, just tie it in a knot.
Just like that.
- How did you come up with the idea
to make those beautiful
mushroom ornaments?
- [Sophia] Oh my gosh!
- [Drew] 'Cause they're so pretty.
- So someone on TikTok did it.
My friend Brit saw it.
She made some, I was obsessed.
And then we started making
them over the holiday.
And I kid you not, I lost like,
four nights of my life.
I was just at the kitchen table.
- Just making mushrooms?
- Crafting like this.
- My fiance was like, "Are you okay?"
I was like, "Yeah, I'm great.
"This is amazing, I love
everything that's happening here."
(audience laughs)
- And yet like, Instagram
is shutting you down
and I wanna purchase one.
So no lost time, in my opinion.
Okay, Sarah.
- I love a good ornament.
- Yeah, then you make a knot
and you slide it off, yeah.
Just slide it off.
And that's it.
Then you end up getting
something that looks like this.
So in front of all of us, we already have
one that's pre-wrapped.
Okay, so pick up your other one.
So what you do is you get
another piece of t-shirt,
and you wrap it around
to make an accent color.
And then, y'all, you take your scissors.
We've got some extra scissors here.
- Do we cut the bottom?
- Yep, you wanna cut the bottom.
And just trim it up, trim
it up however you want.
They kind of remind me of Fry Guys.
Do you know what Fry Guys are?
- No, I do not.
- Remember those guys from McDonalds?
The little Fry Guys?
- Oh! The Fry Guys!
The old mascot things?
- Yeah, that's what they
remind me of, Fry Guys.
- Be careful with scissors.
- What happened to mine?
(audience laughs)
- No, Drew, that's good!
- This is the one I made.
- [Sarah] No, you pick up the big one.
- Oh! There we go!
All right, Sarah, this is my point though.
It's...
- Well, in all fairness,
we didn't give you a long
enough piece to make that one,
for sake of TV, so.
- No, this is why I appreciate you
and what you do.
Because this is what I would've done
and this is what you do.
I think yours is very attractive
and I really do love this garland.
That would make an amazing
decoration in a room.
- Absolutely, it sure would.
And you know what else
you can do with these?
- What?
- You could put them on tents.
- How? Like...
- You can tie these on your tent.
Yeah.
- [Leo] Like a tent ornament.
- Well, also if you go
like, on designer websites,
they're there and then they
charge an arm and a leg for it.
- [Sarah] Exactly, 'cause
that's the whole DIY...
- [Sophia] Oh yeah, people selling
mushroom ornaments on Etsy are charging
a real arm and a leg, let me tell you.
- I love it!
(audience applauds)
Thank you guys so much.
(upbeat music)